[ Piano music - begins and continues throughout the video ]
[Piano music continues]
[Gene Kelly] I told you over and over again
for God's sake, I felt glad,
glad I was out of that ship.
[Male voice - off camera] Is that all?     [Gene Kelly] Yes. Yes! Yes.
[Piano music continues]
[Cartoon character #1 - male voice] The smoke from your factory, it's destroyingmy home, my my health my
[Cartoon character #2 - male voice] We too are concerned about that pressing problem.
Here, let me
show you some of our ads on air pollution.
[Piano music continues]
[Young woman] All these your babies Miss Mary?
[Older woman] Yes, these are all my babies.
Delivered about 1400, counting the ones come this year.
[Piano music continues]
[Narrator] It was Louis Pasteur who smashed the belief
that microbes came into existence by spontaneousgeneration.
His opponents shouted and ranted
against him but he performed his experiments
and silenced the unbelievers with indisputable facts.
[Piano music continues]
[Female actor speaking in scene] ... raining so long there's dust in the road.
[Female actor speaks off camera] some of it got in my throat.  I won'thave you worry about me.
[Female actor speaking in scene]  I'm all right [she coughs]
[Female voice speaks off camera] ... it's late, you have to get up early to go to work.
[Piano music continues]
[Young man speaks off camera] ... and I read this case history of
this guy who had had pneumonia
and every symptom that he had I had.
[Young man] I went straight to my doctor and hediagnosed me as having pneumonia and AIDS,virtually there in his office on the spot.
[Piano music continues]
[President Roosevelt] For we cannot be a strong nation
unless we are a healthy nation
and so we must recruit not only men and
materials but also knowledge and science.
[Piano music continues]
[Piano music fades into silence]